précédemment dedans les merguez de
l'amour yann le bachelor avait toujours
la merguez tiraillé entre deux barbecues
celui de daniel moreau et celui 10
bosc qui se chamaillaient donc pour la
haine des grecs comme on l'appelle dans
le métier je merguez de yann
vendredi cyril sont cupides ans à
babouche lui a organisé deux deit à la
fois intense et qui peut honnêtement
bachelot rld
je suis tellement bouillante jeu greer
est à merguez des rendez vous durant
lesquelles la température n'a fait que
grimper malgré le bon temps passé son
ami cyril le rappelle à ses obligations
j'avais une merguez ne peut pas gagner
sur deux barbus quand même à camden
semblait alors avoir fait le choix
d'acquis rsa merguez après ce malheureux
lapsus
comment leur rendez vous de ce soir va
t-il se passer
la magie va-t-elle opérer mais aussi
qu'à penser le rapport nasa de toute
cette séquence
les scieries regardez ils sont là ils
sont dans ma loge
ils sont en train de dîner
tranquillement tous les deux merguez
contre dernier rien dans les verres
alors on va les écouter ou regarder très
heureux de vous voir ce soir aussi vous
avez mis les petits plats dans les
grands
ces huit l'argent devant nos paroles
oui je me noie dans ton regard elle est
évidemment et d'eau fraîche tout à fait
je passe un moment merveilleux
d'ailleurs merci cyril tu nous avais
promis ce dîner dans ta loge mais y'a
rien à manger a rien à boire mais c'est
comme d'habitude des promesses ne suffit
pas a largement je suis complètement je
suis comblé dalian comblé mais moi j'ai
c'est marrant ce jeu j'ai tout le temps
faim la gpe sein du tout ah oui mon
bonheur étais je plus tard de piano
romantique comme vous me couper un petit
peu l'appétit parce que je suis très ému
je vous coupe l'appétit un petit peu
parce que je suis très ému et ces voix
là je ne sais même plus je perds mes
mots et c'est pas souvent c'est vrai et
je me noie dans vos yeux parole à cette
bourg et là il faut de menois a noyé
dans le champagne et m'annonce nous a
plu pas très sexy est ce que votre peau
est moi j'en ai je le jeu les nantais
temps c'est vrai ah oui on a largué et
c'est avec magnifique je serais ravi que
ça vous plaise et un merveilleux moment
j'espère qu'on mord passé de trop
peut-être plus petit comité
sans les caméras impôts c'est une
invitation c'est l'étape d'après on va
écouter avec plaisir
l'actrice ait pas trop de temps à perdre
assez il faut avancer maintenant parce
que ça piétine un petit peu la dose vous
là d un peu plus vite
daniel un petit daniel oui qu'est ce que
vous espérez de ce rendez vous avec
j'espère énormément parce que cyril vous
le savez je n'ai pas vu le loup depuis
belle lurette élections pour les jeunes
je n'ai pas ken depuis un bail voilà je
fais pour les vieux pour les jeunes et
donc alors moi ce que je peux vraiment
dire scellé puisque ce que j'espère ce
que je ce dont je rêve
ben oui dans mes rêves les plus fous oui
yann j'aimerais que vous me montrez
votre vote ça commence par un b votre
boîte à chocolat
non
[Musique]
du coup la bande à daniel à la plata
diallo très bien celui-là